so welcome everybody to my talk about
the paper small hazard tree transducers
this is joint work of christophe lansin
moti medina and myself i am johannesbund
what we are studying is the complexity
of circuits in ternary logic
the variant of ternary logic we are
looking at was introduced by steven
colglini
what we do is we take the set of boolean
values and add a third logical value
the value is called u
which is an abbreviation for uncertain
you can be regarded as the superposition
of the boolean values which means that
you may evaluate
eventually to 0 1 or at some point
but the evaluation of u is
unpredictable so for worst case analysis
we say that uncertainty
propagates
a u will always stay a u
as an example for what is the difference
between binary and ternary logic we can
look at the law of non-contradiction
in binary logic x and not x will always
evaluate to zero for any value that we
plug into variable x
internal logic the law is not true
anymore we can plug in value u
then u and not u will evaluate to u
instead of zero
so
this is why the law does not hold
anymore
what is our motivation to look into
ternary logic well eventually the inputs
to a circuit will be analog signals
binary values are just an abstraction of
these analog signals with a third
logical value we cover analog behavior
that cannot be clearly interpreted as 0
1.
for circuits we want to compute the most
precise output in phase of uncertain
inputs
so
we call circuits that compute the most
precise output in phase of uncertainty
hazard free circuits
we can also define formally what is a
hazard free circuit
but to do so i need to introduce two
tools and map from the ternary world to
binary and back
there is the resolution that produces a
set of binary words from a ternary input
and a superposition that maps a set of
binary inputs to a ternary word
first the resolution is formally given
by the set of all binary words that
match input x in every position where x
is not uncertain
think of it as replacing each u
in x by
zero and one
second the superposition which is
denoted by the star operator
compares two binary words bit by bit and
replaces every position that does not
match by a u
the formal definition is given for two
words but because of associativity and
commutativity
this can be applied to any set
regardless of the order of application
take this example
for example the resolution of
0u
is the set 0 0 0 0 0 1 0 1 0 and 0 1 1.
so we replace every occurrence of a u by
0 and 1.
on the other hand the superposition of
words 0 1 0 and 0 0 1
is the word zero uu so
each position that does not match is
replaced by u
with these two tools at hand we can
define the hazard free extension of a
function
assume we are given a function f that is
defined in binary words
then its hazard freed
then its hazard free extension is
denoted by f subscript u
and it is defined by looking at each
possible resolution of the input
evaluating each resolution
and taking the star of all
of all evaluations
and that's basically the definition of a
hazard free circuit as well
a circuit c implementing function f has
a hazard if there is an input x
that may have some uncertainty
such that the output of c on x does not
match the hazard free extension of f
applied to x
so and finally a circuit is hazard free
if it has no hazards
please note that it is equivalent to say
that circuit c implements f subscript u
or
circuit c implements f and circuit c is
hazard 3.
before we come to our result let me show
you what is known on hazard free
circuits
first by huffman
we know that every boolean function has
a hazard free implementation
this means for any function f there is a
circuit c that implements f subscript u
next by ikenmeyer and his co-authors we
know that there is an exponential gap
between boolean circuit size
and hazard free circuit size
to be more specific there exists a
family of functions
such that for any function f from this
family the following holes
the smallest boolean circuit
implementing f
is
exponentially smaller than the smallest
circuit implementing f subscript u
so these two statements raise the
question whether there are functions
that have an efficient hazard free
implementation
finally this brings us to the results
that we want to present today
so
all transducers have an efficient hazard
free implementation
transducers are defined the usual way
there is a melee machine with state
space state space s
starting state s0
input alphabet sigma output alphabet
lambda and transition and output
functions tno
for an input sequence of fixed length n
the meaning machine induces a
transcription function tau
so the main result of the presented
paper is that there is a hazard free
circuit implementing transcription
function tau
and
the circuit has
size linear in n and depth logarithmic n
to be more specific the size is given by
2 to the size of the state space plus
the size of the input encoding times n
and the depth of the circuit is given by
the size of the state space times log n
plus the size of the input encoding
which means for constant size state
space and constant size input encoding
this is asymptotically optimal
though
constants might get large and
impractical for large machines
what is under the hood of this
construction is the parallel prefix
computation of lightning fissure
it is known for producing fast circuits
for addition and it is still used in
adders today
but there is more to it zartner and
fischer not only describe how to do
addition they actually present a
framework that can turn any transducer
into an efficient circuit
in general the problem is that states
traversed by the melee machine can only
be computed sequentially
the transition function t can only
compute state i
from the previous state as i minus 1 and
input sigma i
following this scheme would give us a
circuit of linear depth this would be
sub-optimal in their solution lartna and
fischer recognize that composition of
functions is associative
instead of applying the transition
function one by one on each new state
the transition functions are composed
together to function pi i
pi i then is applied to the starting
state s0
as function composition is associative
all pi i can be computed by a circuit
with logarithmic depth
unfortunately the scheme does not
directly apply to hazard free circuits
and the problem here is that encoding
matters a lot in the ternary world
for general construction lardner and
fisher hint at encoding the transition
function by a state transition matrix
in phase of uncertainty the state
transition matrix loses information that
cannot be recovered later
for example look at the depicted state
machine
if we are in state 0 and our input is
uncertain so it's 0 1 then we take
either transition 0 or we take a
transition 1. we cannot be sure whether
we end up in state 0 or state 1.
unfortunately the standard state
transition matrix loses track of the
fact that we are in either state 0 or
state 1.
in the example we can see that the state
machine certainly moves to state 0 if we
receive a clear zero input afterwards
but as the encoding loses strike we
cannot retain this information
our solution is to use a matrix that
encodes not only the transition from one
state to the next
but also the transitions for every
possible subset of the state space
this may seem redundant at first but it
is necessary to keep track of the
information that may be lost due to
uncertainty
getting back to the example if we get an
uncertain input the encoding will become
uncertain about state 0 and state 1
but remain but we remain a certain one
for the union of state 0 and 1.
and we can gain certainty about the
state for a subsequent input zero
so we don't lose
the certainty
before i come to an end i want to
present a possible application of this
framework this is ongoing research and
what we are aiming at is to apply this
framework to addition
a hazard free edition circuit can be
useful in the implementation of clocking
schemes for example
but here again
a major problem is the encoding
take for example the standard binary
encoding
and look at the encoding of 7 which
would be 0 1 1 1. and say we want to add
a single bit that happens to be
uncertain
then the hazard free extension tells us
that the most precise output we can
compute is the superposition of all
possible resolutions
hence we compute seven plus zero which
will be seven so encode it as zero one
one one
and we compute seven plus one which will
be eight so this is encoded as one zero
zero zero
the superposition of both results is the
word
uu
this output does not contain any
certainty at all and even though we know
the output should be seven or eight
hence
there is no chance in using the standard
binary encoding
in our solution we assume that the
uncertainty is bounded this is a fair
assumption for
the clocking applications we are aiming
at
please note that this assumption does
not help in the binary world at all the
previous example already shows that the
smallest amount of uncertainty leads to
fully uncertain output
so what we do is we define a new
encoding that is a combination of unary
encoding and gray code encoding
unary encoding alone would already
suffice to maintain the amount of
uncertainty in the inputs
but it has too much redundancy and is
very large
so please recall that the size of the
input encoding appears as an exponent in
the size of the circuit for our
construction
so we are looking for more efficient
encodings
but encoding still need to have enough
redundancy to cover the uncertainty of
the inputs
for a newly defined encoding addition
schemes are unknown so we have to design
according transducers
then finally we can apply the presented
work to obtain an efficient circuit that
is hazard free
so finally thank you for your attention